a sea of blue in kabul a group of women
gathers at a market
the taliban's latest decree is that all
women in afghanistan must cover their
entire body when they're outside the
home
hijab is a privilege for muslim and
pious women
hijabi women are protected from
disobedience and sins
they'll always be respected they'll be
protected from evil
if a woman is seen in public without
head to toe covering she along with her
husband or male guardian could be
punished
the homes for the women who don't have a
hijab should be known their men should
be advised and warned
the strict enforcement of burqa became a
global symbol of the taliban's rule when
it was in power in the 1990s
since retaking control of afghanistan
last year taliban leaders have
reintroduced restrictions mainly
directed at women
this most recent decree is one of the
harshest yet why is it that only women
issue is a priority for taliban why not
you know policy on
hunger on poverty on lack of jobs on
security
taliban leaders have also cracked down
on education for girls closing down
secondary schools on the same day class
was supposed to start
u.n human rights experts say afghan
women are facing large-scale and
systematic gender-based discrimination
and violence see any of the
demonstrations that have taken place
since august when the taliban took over
it's been women at the forefront women
and girls
and this is intended to
ensure that women have no public face
there are fears the strict rules now
facing women in afghanistan will likely
discourage them from going out in public
and realizing their full potential
leah harding al jazeera